you have threatened to recreate your
beautiful Golden Globes moment which you
must be so regretting as you've done
everywhere you go I'm sure you guys saw
this Brian but we talked about because
Ryan Gosling was on the show yeah weeks
ago Ryan Gosling is getting his award
and that's your wrap you're here
somewhere oh there you are you is that
you oh yeah well I think here over there
but over here stealing the thunder is
filled and run so are you going to do it
at the Oscars it was a ridiculous thing
I said to Ryan Reynolds if you win kids
kiss me instead of your wife and that's
great and the plan was is that he would
kind of move move towards his wife and
then it and then kind of last minute and
then he didn't win much to our
disappointment said to her I said to her
we could still just do it was game but I
love the fact that it was so deep in the
background they said you better have to
kind of look to see if it was actually
with he was unaware of it yeah no I know
you're aware of it in it no
graham norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation